desde cuando se ha empezado a notar el
aumento de emigrantes rusos y ucranianos
en esta frontera y cómo llegan hasta
ella
bueno pues como bien mencionabas está
este aumento se ha dado en los últimos
meses incluso antes del anuncio que
diera el presidente putin de iniciar con
este conflicto militar y como ya lo
mencionaba hay otros países en donde se
están yendo a refugiar pero méxico
también ha sido importante como decíamos
en los últimos cuatro meses han llegado
más ucranianos y rusos de los que
habíamos tenido en todo el año pasado e
incluso si vemos las cifras tú ya
mencionadas algunas pero si vemos de
2018 la fecha a méxico han llegado cerca
de 288 mil rusos tan sólo en estos meses
no enero y febrero han llegado 28 mil
353 entonces una buena cantidad si lo
vemos en esta en esta cuenta desde 2018
lo mismo pasa con el tema de ucrania que
pues han aumentado de manera
significativa en donde pues si vemos tan
solo las cifras de enero y febrero
tenemos cerca de 9 mil 903 personas de
ucrania creo que esto se puede deber uno
por un lado al inminente peligro de la
guerra que ya se veía entonces la
frontera con méxico sin duda es una
frontera importante porque también de
aquí pueden cruzar hacia los eeuu más
ahora que se calcula que más de un
millón de personas han abandonado ya el
territorio en ucrania en el caso de las
visas eb alguien ya anunció que va a dar
un estatus temporal con incluso un
permiso de un año y medio para poder
trabajar por allá y algunos apoyos a las
personas que lleguen desde ucrania en el
caso de méxico también se ha hecho un
anuncio de que se va a apoyar con el
refugio a las personas que estén o que
lleguen y pidan está esta figura
humanitaria en nuestro territorio tanto
de rusia como de ucrania es lo que se ha
mencionado en el caso del instituto
nacional de migración y aquí nada más la
cuestión es subrayar que hemos tenido un
reto tanto eeuu como méxico en términos
de refugio en los últimos años incluso
pues mucha gente se ha quedado varada en
la frontera mexicana y pidiendo el
refugio en eeuu entonces ahora tenemos
esta situación de guerra y se van a
hacer algunas cuestiones excepcionales
pero sí creo que hay que reflexionar
sobre todos los pendientes también de en
ambos países pero tan solo sernac cerró
el año pasado con 130.000 solicitudes de
las cuales solamente pudo dar solución a
cerca de 30.000
precisamente del estatus legal que
tienen los migrantes quería hablarle
usted ha comentado que bardem que el
gabinete de biden va a ofrecer
soluciones a los migrantes rusos y
ucranianos pero ahora mismo en qué
estatus legal quedan estos migrantes si
logran entrar a eeuu
bueno ante el anuncio de bailén
justamente se les va a otorgar a los que
logren ingresar una amnistía temporal
que va a ser a todos estos que ya han
llegado en estos en estos meses y será
un beneficio como el que en su momento
se hizo por otras cuestiones también a
los salvadoreños por ejemplo
centroamericanos de estatus temporal
especial y bueno en este caso va en esto
entró en vigor desde el primero de marzo
este este anuncio de bai ling y va a
brindarles como te mencionaba un permiso
de trabajo de año y medio y pues este
protección temporal de estatus
migratorio que está por el departamento
de seguridad interior también en eeuu
entonces si podrá seguramente acceder
hay que ver ya ahora en la realidad cómo
se da porque eso es donde creo que puede
haber algunos problemas por todas las
dificultades que ha habido y la lentitud
con que se han seguido los procesos de
refugio tanto en méxico como en eeuu si
brevemente usted ha hablado de migrantes
salvadoreños
precisamente en los últimos años hemos
venido hablando de olas migratorias cómo
puede afectar esta nueva ola a los
migrantes que ya están en la frontera
mexicana con estados unidos
bueno pues justamente en este momento en
la frontera de méxico con estados unidos
tenemos a los solicitantes de refugio en
eeuu es decir a todos los
centroamericanos que están solicitando
esta figura humanitaria en eeuu están
hoy esperando en mexico por el programa
the remaining méxico o permanece en
mexico que desafortunadamente a pesar de
que bardem no había cancelado o
calificado como inhumano al principio de
su mandato la suprema corte justicia lo
obliga a reiniciarlo y bueno ahí lo
tenemos ya desde hace tres meses de
nuevo en 6 puntos fronterizos esto
además aunado a todos los retornos por
título 42 que nos han hecho es decir
diariamente dejan a personas de
centroamérica en la frontera mexicana
con el pretexto de la pandemia y del
peligro de la salud pública para los
estadounidenses y bueno ahora vamos a
sumarle a estos ucranianos y rusos que
lleguen también y qué bueno intenten
ingresar incluso se ha hablado que
algunos han conseguido autos chocolate
que son estos autos sin placas para
poder ingresar de manera más rápida en
fin yo creo que va a detonar varias
problemáticas pero bueno sí creo que se
va a dar una respuesta más inmediata a
estos ciudadanos que a todos los que ya
venían esperando antes